JOHN ESSIGMANN: I'm always
interested in listening
to JoAnne's lectures,
and she talks
about how she got
interested in biochemistry
from a background
in what I would call
more physical organic chemistry
by attending a lecture
and being completely inspired.
And I am a toxicologist
by training.
And how did that
actually happen.
I have a similarly
inspiring story,
so I thought I would tell that.
I went to a lecture about
45 years ago, by a fellow
by the name of [Richard]
Evans Schultes.
He was the director of
the Herbarium at Harvard--
and I'd been to it; it
was very interesting--
and a professor there.
And he is arguably the father
of the field called ethnobotany.
I went to this talk-- there
were only about 10 people
at the talk.
He-- because it was a small
talk, he gave it sitting down,
he asked permission to do
that, he's a very polite man.
And it was very informal,
only a few slides.
And the slides
were mainly of him
living with indigenous
peoples, Native Americans
in the Southwest,
Amazonian native peoples,
very interesting.
And he talked about, for
example, he had just graduated,
his undergraduate
degree from Harvard.
His parents were eager to
have him go to medical school.
He was very interested in
botany and in native languages.
So he went to live with the--
I think it was the Kiowa
people in the Midwest--
I think it was
probably Oklahoma.
And he learned about peyote
and a lot of other chemicals
that were hallucinogenic.
And he realized, of
course, that many
of these kinds of compounds that
were used in a lot of rituals,
were also medicines at other
concentrations, anesthetics
and so on.
He then went down
to South America,
living with various tribes.
He'd be gone for up
to a year at a time.
There are wonderful stories,
well actually terrible stories,
I guess, about him
paddling his canoe
for 40 days with malaria--
it was terrible-- to get to
a hospital, things like that.
But anyway these are stories--
I was a young scientist
at the time-- these
were very influential to me.
And he talked about, I was down
in South America and they--
and I found the plants from
which the native people got
their dart and arrow poisons.
And he said, out of
that we isolated curare,
and initiated the path
toward the clinic of curare
as a muscle relaxant.
He said that it
didn't work so well.
I remember this lecture
like it was yesterday.
He said that it was the
beginning of World War II,
we were cut off from
the rubber plantations
in the Philippines
and other places.
And since South America
had jungles, his form of,
quote unquote
"military service,"
involved trying to find sources
in the jungle of latex that
could be used to make
rubber so that we could
have an effective war machine.
So anyway, I went up to this
fellow after he gave his talk.
And I said, look, I just got
to do this kind of stuff.
This sounds really interesting.
And he said, what's
your background?
I said, well, you know,
I worked as a chemist.
I was a biology
major but I worked
as a chemist at an
industrial consulting company
during my undergraduate years.
And he said, oh, you got to go
talk with Gerry Wogan at MIT.
He said that he isolates
toxins from fungi
that you find out in the
jungles of Southeast Asia.
And, so anyway, that's
how my career began.
As you know, I got to
eventually meet Gerry Wogan
and work with him.
He had already identified
this toxin, aflatoxin.
But he needed somebody to
figure out how it worked,
and that's how I got my start.
So my interests have been in
chemicals from the environment.
It could be a pollutant.
Or it could be a
chemical that could
be a precursor to
a therapeutically
useful molecule, and
how do they interact
with biological systems.
And that's what toxicologists
and pharmacologists do.